and if i look at you the young people
you have
you're approximately the age of my
children
i have a very clear idea
what your worries are but also what the
opportunities are
we can do something we can fix it and
this is our common vision
and we need you to raise your voice
and to push us hard to move on faster
but we also of course need
your young brilliant minds
to go into research and
innovation and development
and therefore we really need you not
only to be the advocates
of fighting climate change the advocates
of our planet of our nature
but also the ones who develop the
solutions
um so we we do need youth
more than ever before